they pick 26th overall in the upcoming
draft
for which they are the host team i'm
going to cleveland ohio
for the nfl draft next week and the head
coach of the 11 and 5 cleveland browns
after his first highly successful year
as hc of the cleveland browns kevin
stefanski
joining me here on the rich johnson show
how are you sir i'm doing great rich
good to be with you good to be with you
as well let's let's get started about i
i i don't know how often we've ever
gotten a chance to speak
um but uh how many penn quakers
are there in the national football
league right now
kevin do you know the oxymoronic
fighting quakers
very well done not many of us not many
of us uh we've had a couple players over
the years uh and i'm proud of those guys
but i think there need to be more
yeah you know what because we always
hear about you know ryan fitzpatrick
being the harvard guy you know you're
you're you're a pen guy you're a pen
quaker hey i you know i played against
ryan fitzpatrick did you really you can
believe this
tell me about that one what do you got
for me on that uh great player
uh i'm talking about ryan now yeah
obviously no great player
yes he was so athletic for that league
you know you watch him move around
against the nfl imagine what he was
doing
against guys that looked like me uh he
was a threat to run it could throw it
just uh awesome player now if i'm not
mistaken were you a defensive back
were you where you were you were i was i
was a safety
i was very very good at playing very
very deep
that was what i was good at did did
fitzpatrick look you off at one point
did is that what he did
at one point or or is it still the
fitzpatrick we see all the time that you
you actually had tight coverage and you
said screw it he threw into that window
anyway
what happened it was it was fifth magic
back then uh i will tell you we we beat
him so i feel good about that getting a
victory yes
a couple times versus him but uh but it
was in no way was it
brian fitzpatrick versus me because that
that was
advantage crimson kevin stefanski here
uh on the rich eisen show okay and uh
your dad is an nba
executive currently for the pistons as
well did you grow up
i guess in a basketball household in a
way yeah we
did yeah i mean philly's a great
basketball
city great high school basketball great
college basketball so
growing up i spent many a saturday at
the palestra
just different games going to different
practices for for college ball
as a kid and then my dad got in the nba
later on in his career
uh so so he was has been kind of
bouncing around
uh the nba for the last it feels like 25
30 years so uh he gives me a different
perspective
uh you know that sports perspective
where winning and dying
uh winning and losing you're dying with
every game he can appreciate that from a
from a football guy if i told that kid
growing up in that household he's going
to be the head coach of the cleveland
browns one day
what would you have said kevin owed of
that i would never believed it yeah i
mean it's it definitely was
not the plan uh at no point did i set
out and say that rich
i i wanted to be reggie white when i
when when i was growing up
uh so shortly thereafter i realized that
wasn't happening but
uh it's one of those things that you
know i'm blessed to have this role
something i try to do really well and
and take you know
as a steward of the team and take good
care of this team
uh for our fans so was it children's who
gave you a break is that how that worked
in terms of getting you from penn to the
nfl
how did that happen yeah exactly right
so i
took an internship with the philadelphia
eagles in the summer of 2005
which was the eagles summer if you can
remember t.o
uh doing sit-ups there in the driveway
so i i
that was a an impactful internship if
you will
and then uh coach childress got the
vikings job that january
and uh he brought me out there with him
so were you the one
what was your role as an intern this
summer where t.o is doing sit-ups on the
lawn andy reed sends him home
next question with drew rosenhaus i mean
what's an intern do on that front
kevin yeah anything and everything i'm
stocking gatorade
in the in the coolers um i'm driving
players to and from practice
coach nated something i was a gopher
that's how i broke into it that's how
you break into it
did you pick anything i like so so when
you're coaching now you're the hc now
and and you're and you're giving
directives in any way shape or form
who are you sometimes picking stuff up
from that you're like something comes
out of your mouth and you you picked it
up from somebody would it be andy reid
who would it be
walk me through your influences before
we get to the here and now kevin
yeah i'm so lucky in that regard rich
i've been around some
incredible coaches and and coach
childress was a was a great program
builder if you can take yourself back to
2006 at the vikings
we went six and ten eight and eight ten
and six twelve and four
uh so it just was to watch him operate
with the program and then just being
around
leslie frazier uh who did it a different
way but just a great man
uh mike zimmer uh who's i think the
premier
defense of mine in the game and then i
was so fortunate enough to be around
pat shurmur north turner bill musgrave
and then really
in that last year the vikings spend the
calendar year with gary kubiak
was as impactful as they come kevin
stefanski cleveland brown's head coach
here on the rich housing show what
clicked for you
last year for the for you at the browns
what do you think clicked
in a way that uh yeah that you're
appreciative of or
surprised you any way shape or form
kevin yeah i think we had a bunch of
players rich that that wanted to work
and that's what we put the focus on
uh from the jump i felt there were some
really good people
already in the building when i got here
and then through the draft and free
agency and trades
we added a bunch of smart and tough
football players and
i think if i'm proud of one thing it's
that the guys went out there
and we stuck to the plan and and really
stayed in the moment throughout the
season so
as you know it's a it can be a long year
and
the best line i've heard is it's not a
marathon it's 16
sprints and i need to update that to 17
sprints right so
if you if you treat it as such which i
think we did i think you really put the
focus on winning
uh that week winning one game that week
i think that's what the guys did
i don't know if you were aware kevin
stefanski but you're gonna be the first
head coach that baker mayfield has
enjoyed
uh at his side uh or attached to the hip
with
for consecutive years since bob stoops
in oklahoma
the guys constantly had change you know
and then when lincoln riley showed up he
left
you know to go into the pros and uh
i am wondering what you and he
clicked about last year in a manner that
we are seeing him play his best football
since coming to the pros yeah when i
think of baker and and i
talked to him yesterday and when i think
about him as as a player he's a gym rat
he wants to get better and whatever you
give him
he takes coaching there there were
things that alex van pelt
our offensive coordinator did with baker
last year and challenged him
and changed some things in his footwork
and and we pushed him
and probably put him under center than
he has more than he has been
uh at least in recent years so he he was
so
open to coaching and then just the way
he grinds in his preparation
that's the thing that a lot of people
don't see that that i really appreciate
about baker and it's something
uh that i think he'll continue to do i
don't i don't ever get the sense
from baker that he's satisfied i think
he wants to continue to grind
day in and day out so then what's your
what's your envision
what's your vision for his next steps in
2021 what do you got for me on that yeah
i think i look back to our first year
together
uh he got better as the season wore on
and it
it was a combination of things i mean
the credit goes to baker
uh for putting the work uh in but we
also streamlined a lot of the concepts
of what we were doing found out what he
was comfortable because we really were
learning about each other
uh as we went so i feel like our jumping
off point in year two
is so different from where we started uh
so
that's where he he will always go into a
season
and i think he would agree he wants to
take another step
and i think he took a step last year and
and we're working real hard to make sure
he takes another step this year well
what specific
can you give me for a next step in terms
of
development mechanics uh recognition
what do you got for me
on that well i would tell you rich with
all these guys we meet with them and we
give them a list of things
that he needs to work on some of them
are simple like you mentioned mechanics
it might be
footwork in the gun it could be his uh
carrying out his fake could be specific
stats like let's get that completion
percentage up
uh up around 70 and i think those type
of things happen when you
employ the check down when you need to
so it's really just a total maturation
of the player and i think it's something
that he really is embracing
is it uh also again just rumor you can
confirm it
is it true that your coaching style is
so uh deep and unique that you had
uh aliens and ufos tell him this
personally
to try and confirm your coaching at all
kevin is that true
i haven't i haven't addressed that yet
i'll see if that comes up
uh but i read that as everybody else
hey i i can't i wasn't there so i can't
tell you what happened okay yeah okay
just wonder if you've actually
approached that subject or
you sent them to him to say hey get that
completion percentage up
oh my god you know like i don't know if
that's your style kevin
no that's me that's not a bad idea i'm
always thinking about new ways to reach
our players next level
let me give that some thought you're
welcome is all i have to say on that
kevin stefanski here
uh on the rich eisen show how is odell
what do you got for me on that front
on odell beckham's recovery here
adele's doing well i talked to him often
he's working very hard as as i'm sure
everyone has seen
through some of his videos uh he's in a
really good place i think he's
he's progressing nicely and i'm excited
to
uh finally get him back here on campus
at some point i don't know if you're
aware of this narrative that was quite
popular
during your 11 win regular season and uh
and the playoff run that you went on
last year coach
but i'd love to give you the floor on
the narrative that your offense is
better
without odell beckham how do you respond
to that
yeah that that was the narrative rich i
got asked that often
i think our offense got better period as
the season wore on and i think that
again is the natural evolution
of a new scheme new coaches with new
players i i
we better improve as the season wore on
i think we took a big jump
after at the bye week we had eight games
last year and then had a buy
and we looked very hard at what we were
good at what we weren't so good at
and and like good coaches do i think our
coaches did a nice job of identifying
some things that we wanted to do
differently
so i think we just got better because
that's how it goes
in a season when when you have a new
scheme uh to say you take a player of
odell's caliber
off your roster and you somehow get
better i don't buy into that at all
so was there is there anything to that
baker
might have uh without odell there
felt less compelled to force an
individual the ball
in any way shape or form what about that
narrative
yeah i don't buy it uh we we work really
hard with the quarterbacks
in in terms of their reads i mean it's
what you try as a quarterback coach uh
you try to
eliminate the gray for the quarterback
so he has reads based on the coverage
and the ball goes where the ball goes
and i think
we're very fortunate to have on our
offense
and that you know a bunch of guys
returning uh we have players that
i feel strongly about at every level i
brought him back a tight end at wide
receivers so
uh odell adds obviously a huge element
of uh an explosive nature to our offense
he's he's that front of mind as we put
our scheme together
but to force the ball to somebody i
think
is not something that we'll do here
because it's not good for
the overall offense so i don't i just
don't buy that aspect of it
but i also don't want to shortchange
odell's uh
ability to affect the game uh week in
and week out a few more minutes left
with cleveland brown's head coach kevin
stefanski here on the rich eisen show
the acquisition of jadav and county does
that take pressure off of getting that
edge rusher
where you're so deep down in the draft
to 26 overall
or would you choose another one there
how does this affect your draft strategy
kevin's defense yeah i think we're we're
open for improving the team
at a bunch of positions rich uh we're
excited about to deviant and what he can
bring to that front
uh but as as you well know you can never
have enough the end you
never have enough linebackers corners i
mean you need good players uh
on the defense period so whether we go
defense or offense i just think we're
going to be able to sit there and
allow the board to come to us and say we
have to take a good player that's going
to help us and
help us in year one and then also help
us you know in year four five and six
so i i think the things we've done in
free agency certainly
we feel good about adding to our team uh
we added a lot of players to our defense
but we just feel like we need to add
more more depth uh that that will allow
us to
to play with with different uh units if
you will and have different personnel in
the field but
i don't think it precludes us from doing
anything there at 26. well i mean
all i hear is how weak this draft is at
the defensive tackle position
and sheldon richardson i appears to have
been a cap casualty
with the signing of of clowney is it
possible you could bring him back
in cleveland you know i'm i'm hopeful uh
sheldon
gave us incredible production last year
played
through injuries and what i remember
about last year as we're going
on that run and we needed to win some
games to get in uh
sheldon was at the forefront of that and
he had not been to the playoffs
before in his career so he took great
pride in what he was able to accomplish
uh on our defense and in propelling us
in into those playoffs so
i'm hopeful rich you know this is a
business i get to sit
and look at it from the head coach chair
and i tell our general manager hey why
can't we keep everybody
and you know he's smart enough to
realize and he has a plan
uh but but it's part of the the nature
of the cap
um you sometimes have to make hard
decisions but yes i am hopeful uh that
that a scenario like that could could
happen
last one for you coach stefanski um
i pound the table from this desk and
uh on this particular subject and
uh i've been with the nfl network since
2003 so i know
uh changing rules in the nfl is all
about consensus building
in last year's playoff loss in kansas
city you were having a heck of a drive
to close the end of the first half
ball gets popped loose good hit by the
defense although it might
have been an illegal hit but ball pops
free
had it rolled out of bounds you'd have
gotten the ball right there instead it
just rolls into the end zone and out of
bounds you lose the football i hate that
rule with a passion
and the fury of a million sons can i
count on your vote
to get rid of this rule in the national
football league kevin stefanski
you know rich i never thought about the
rule
and i knew what the rule was i know how
penalizing it is when it happens
right so i just focused on coaching the
guys
not to reach it over unless especially
in a crowd unless it was fourth down or
something
so i think it's something that i would
support us looking at
um but i know that it that was one play
in that ball game
and and i know i know it's an impactful
play but i could
pick out ten others that i wish the
result was different as well no i
understand you got to play better than
the refs ref too
uh coach i i understand but i just don't
understand why
if the ball had gotten popped out and
rolled
directly out of bounds to the right you
get to keep it
but because it rolls a little bit
further and through the end zone you
don't and the kansas city defense gets
bailed out
because of it i would love to get rid of
that rule give you the ball maybe on the
20-yard line and call it the same down
and distant you know the same uh
down and now that's the distance to the
goal you have a reverse touch back but
at least you get a shot to the end zone
or get a chance to kick a field goal out
of it
you don't get zero and say sorry for the
effort go back to your locker room
i hate that i i think it will ha if if
we
frame this as the rich eyes and
resolutions yes sir i think it's got a
chance
you know coach you you you uh you're
very good at what you do
not just coaching but i like your brain
from the neck up my brother's a wharton
school of business graduates so maybe
that's something too
um and you know and you know how to give
me an answer while uh
stroking my ego well done a plus
i i appreciate it coach you can always
tell a michigan man but you can't tell
them too much
is that is that a compliment is that i'm
trying to you
yeah i think you got to think long and
hard about it but you can use that one
coach stefanski much appreciated let's
do this more often and uh i hope to uh
run into you uh next week although i'm
sure you'll be in your draft room but
i'll be in your town i do hope to see
you
yeah excellent excited for everybody to
get out here to cleveland and put our
city
uh showcase it to a global audience
appreciate the time here kevin stefanski
much appreciated that's the cleveland
browns head coach here on the rich eisen
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here